hey guys it is the 11 too much today my
name is Jeff McDowell and you're
watching gamespot news Sony is taken to
cutting the fat from its company in
recent times and it seems the next
division to go is PlayStation mobile
sony have announced that playstation
mobile which is in essence a framework
for PS vita and android indie titles
will be shut down as of july 15 this
year as of sep tember town you'll no
longer be able to make in-app purchases
or redownload previously purchased
content although if you've already
downloaded that content it will still be
available to use to ensure you keep it
you'll have to activate your PS vita or
Android device using a set of
instructions you can find on gamespot
more mortal kombat x characters have
been confirmed today and there's also a
slew of images for you to peruse series
regulars Johnny Cage and Molina are set
to return as playable fighters in the
upcoming game according to an update to
the games amazon listing the listing
also features the first official images
of these characters as they'll appear in
the game news that Johnny Cage would
feature in the new game link in a video
interview on game crate last week but
has since been removed cages daughter
Cathy is also making an appearance in
Mortal Kombat X which will be out on
April 14 across consoles and PC if
you're waiting on your next dose of
nathan drake goodness you may want to
settle in since uncharted 4 has been
delayed until spring of 2016 the 2015
delay train is really getting underway
with both uncharted 4 and project cars
getting their release dates knocked back
today game directors Neil druckmann and
Bruce Straley released a statement on
the Uncharted
or delay that red it's become clear to
us that this game is much more ambitious
than we originally envisioned so we've
made the difficult choice of pushing the
game's release date giving us a few
extra months we'll make certain that
unchaste for a thief and not only meet
the team high standard but the high
standards the gamers have come to expect
from a naughty dog title uncharted 4 was
originally scheduled to land sometime
this year but Naughty Dog are promising
that the big delay will be totally worth
it in the end let me know down in the
comments if you're alright with
uncharted 4 getting delayed or not and
why you can head to gamespot well we've
got stories on the delay of project cars
and evolves launch success those are all
the good things that I wanted to tell
you about today about i'll be back same
time tomorrow with a bunch of one year
so check back with me then